10 à 13h de travail par jour 6 jours sur
7 à faire des tâches d'entretien ménager
ou à organiser des activités pour
divertir les campeurs pour un salaire
d'un peu moins de 4 dollars de l'heure
voilà la réalité des crises par deux
travailleurs mexicains du camping Havana
de marico qui ont accepté de témoigner
sous couvert de l'anonymat en raison de
la situation précaire liée à leur statut
juridique au pays
de cette manière c'était vraiment
humiliant il nous payait 300$ par
semaine
on était vraiment payés très peu
l'employeur leur aurait demandé
d'arriver au Canada en tant que touriste
puis l'aurait promis qu'un permis de
travail leur serait délivrer plus tard
après leur arrivée promesse qui n'aurait
jamais été tenu
il nous disait si tu fais pas bien ton
travail tu en auras pas de permis c'est
le genre de pression qu'ils utilisaient
presque tous les jours
[Musique]
sans un permis de travail il est illégal
pour les travailleurs étrangers
d'occuper un emploi au Canada pour moi
c'est carrément d'être humain qu'on a
fait chez benaclome le réseau d'aide aux
travailleuses et travailleurs migrants
agricoles du Québec estiment que les
agissements du camping Havana en plus
d'être illégaux ont maintenu des
travailleurs dans une situation de
grande précarité
de travail sont pas protégés si ils
n'ont pas le droit à l'assurance maladie
lorsqu'on fait venir avec des permis de
touristes ça coûte rien
quand rien d'employeur puis ça leur
permet aussi de les exploiter encore
plus en sachant très bien qu'ils sont
des illégaux c'est avocat spécialisé en
droit de l'immigration croit aussi que
la situation peut être décrite comme de
la traite de la personne qui va
entièrement organise la venue
d'immigrants au Canada pour réduire en
erreur peut être considéré pour du
trafic de personnes le responsable du
camping à vana Resort juge qui n'a rien
à se reprocher parce que moi j'avais
promis je l'ai très bien fait depuis
encore plus mais
quant aux employés de l'animation
Dominique Perrier soutien qu'il n'avait
pas besoin de permis de travail
puisqu'il est considère comme des
artistes et qu'aucun salaire n'aurait
été versé puisqu'ils étaient bénévoles
tant que ça reste dans le domaine
artistique que c'était des gens de nous
nous conseillers juridiques de aucun
problème il y a aucun problème pour
faire la façon de notre façon à nous des
invités pour les connaître une faire
connaître en même temps ça prend un
permis de travail trois experts en
immigration consultés par Radio-Canada
sont catégoriques l'exception qui est
prévue pour les artistes ne s'appliquent
pas aux animateurs embauchés dans un
camping pour plusieurs semaines ici
Thomas Dehaye Radio-Canada Sherbrooke